[Music]
every Disney story ends with a happily
ever after but what happens next let's
find out have you ever wondered what
Bell was like as a mom stick around to
find out
first time at the things smash that
subscribe button so you'll never miss a
thing don't forget to give this video a
big thumbs up now let's see what
happened to Belle after happily ever
after Beauty and the Beast is one of the
most iconic and beloved Disney stories
the original film was part of the Disney
Renaissance it introduced the world to a
new princess and told a classic French
tale in style with award-winning songs
and a talented cast it instantly became
a fan favorite it also gave us one of
the best villains in Disney history
Gaston
we loved to hate that muscle-bound Oh
Gaston you've got to pull yourself
together seriously who eats that many
eggs he could single-handedly cause a
worldwide egg shortage and worldwide
chickens to go on strike with those
demands disgusting Gaston aside the rest
of the story is magical the movie was
fantastic but the core story is just as
good Belle's father disappears in a dark
wood during a terrible storm she had
already lost her mother and was
determined to get her father back
possessing all the courage of a Disney
Princess Belle set off into the scary
woods she tracked her father's Partin
horse to an old castle inside she met
Beast at first she sees him as cruel and
terrifying which he is but he's at least
willing to release Belle's sick father
but only if she agrees to stay forever
perhaps he was driven by loneliness
maybe beast was hoping for a happy
ending all along no matter why he asked
Belle agrees to stay she spends her time
reading in the vast library and getting
to know the staff want to see me do a
trick
none of them are in their true form the
entire castle and everyone in it were
cursed by a Crone after Prince Adam was
cruel and selfish during her time in the
castle Belle begins to see who Beast
truly is she can't help but fall in love
with his intelligence education and
kindness in him she is finally found the
perfect reading partner Belle falls in
love with the Beast for who he really is
Belle's love for Beast overcame almost
impossible odds she's willing to stand
with him no matter what her love and
dedication will be put to the ultimate
test outside of the castle the villagers
have a very different idea of who the
Beast is Gaston whips the villagers into
an angry mob he has them convinced beast
is a dangerous threat to them all who
must be killed to keep the village safe
they're easily convinced that Beast is
their enemy even though they've never
met him they take up their torches and
pitchforks and head to the castle
led by Gaston the mob makes its way to
the castle for a dramatic and violent
confrontation the end of the film is
full of action and suspense the mob
overtakes the castle and forces its way
inside beast is attacked and really
badly hurt
Gaston loses his life and since he's not
really the good guy in this story after
all it's hard to feel bad for him after
the way he behaved as eyebrow-raising as
Gaston was his death was still tragic
despite the challenges Belle and Beast
drive off the villagers after Belle and
Beast defeat the angry mob the curse is
broken
her love restores Beast to his true form
the story ends with everyone joyously
transforming back into who they really
are and reuniting with their loved ones
while the ending is a magical happily
ever after
we can't help but wonder what happens
after the movie ends come on you know
you've wondered to what it bells wedding
dress look like how did Prince Adam
propose there's so much left to discover
after the movie there are a lot of loose
ends that need to be tied up not too
that the story ends just before some
serious historical events we're gonna
take a look at how a wealthy prince and
his new bride made it through the French
Revolution but let's not get ahead of
ourselves let's start at the beginning
as the movie ends Belle and Prince Adam
are in love the curse has been lifted
from their castle and all their friends
have been returned to their true forms
as they begin to rebuild and repair the
castle their bond offense they are
making a home together they're building
a life together as any couple would they
begin to think about the future a girl
deserves a ring after she saves you from
an angry mob right Belle is smart brave
and willing to love the prince as a
grumpy beast anyone would be crazy not
to put a ring on it
wedding bells seem to be in the air
Prince Adam was probably egged on by his
overly romantic friend Lumiere and an
epic proposal is planned mrs. Potts
probably lent her a feminine perspective
too she has a real soft spot for Belle
and would want her special moment to be
perfect
given how much the library means to
Belle it's a natural choice for a
location red roses her favorite flower
would drip from every surface
Lumiere no doubt would encourage the
prince to think of every little detail
champagne chocolate and of course the
perfect ring obviously Belle says yes to
her beloved prince who could resist a
dream proposal in a fairytale castle
it's a moment straight out of the books
Belle loves to read the royal engagement
isn't the only change coming to the
castle Belle has a plan to help Prince
Adam get back on the public's good side
the last time we saw the villagers they
weren't exactly welcoming to the Beast a
pitchfork wielding mob at your door
isn't a sign of being a respected
monarch just because he transformed back
into his human form doesn't mean that
the public will trust him
the Prince needs to repair his public
image and his future wife is just the
person to do it
Belle's love of reading gave actress
Emma Watson a clear idea of Belle's next
move Emma played Belle in the 2017
live-action film
she has a unique perspective into the
characters mind she sees Belle opening
the castle library to the public we
can't say she's wrong it was amazing
this seems exactly what Belle would do
perhaps serving her community as a
librarian may not seem like the perfect
job for a future princess dusty stacks
of books aren't the first thing that
comes to mind when we think of royalty
but Belle isn't your average princess
she values her mind above her tiara well
some people use their imagination and
that's exactly why we love her she's
happy to be an educator and public
servant
she's from humble roots and was never
very motivated by glitz and glam not a
lot of her neighbors seem to be able to
read this would definitely get to
Belle's tender heart we imagine her
teaching villagers to read as part of
her library program she would definitely
want to share the joy she found in books
it's a great escape from the toil of
everyday life this would give her and
the Prince a reputation for caring about
their community that's a much better
image than a huge terrifying beast isn't
it the Royal Wedding of Prince Adam and
Belle has some mentions in Disney canon
there's a Disney readalong called
Belle's royal wedding which details the
big day
Belvoir a gorgeous sparkling gown
covered in white rosettes Prince Adam
wore the blue and gold suit you'd expect
the day was filled with laughter and
love Belle and Prince Adam obviously
improved their public image before the
wedding
Lumiere surprises the happy couple by
inviting the entire village to the
wedding the whole town turns out to
cheer and celebrate sharing this special
day with their subjects would further
cement their relationships not every
royal wedding is open to the public
knowing Lumiere and his team the affair
was probably over the top it would have
been the party of the century it may
have been the most exciting night of
many of the villagers lives Beauty and
the Beast is set in late 1700s France
historically this was a crazy time for
France everyone but the rich was
starving to death the working-class rose
up against the wealthy in a violent
revolution heads were literally rolling
it wasn't a great time to be a rich guy
in a castle Prince Adam would have been
a target his palace wasn't exactly
subtle his wealth was on display and the
villagers may have still had an old
grudge
how did Belle and Prince survive well
there are tons of fan theories some fans
think that Belle's
library went a long way with the
villagers Belle and Prince Adam are both
compassionate people many fans think
that they would have taken action before
the Revolution began feeding the
villagers building community gardens and
lowering taxes in their kingdom could
have earned them brownie points some
fans think the couple would have sided
with a working class and helps their
cause as champions of the people they
would have avoided the dangers other
wealthy families faced many fans
consider the descendants part of
official Disney Canon even if it isn't
official it's certainly the most fun
future we can imagine that means the
formation of auradon is the next chapter
in Belle and beasts happily ever after
story some fans think that Belle and
Prince Adam live in a fairy tale version
of France if that's so the revolution
could have affected all of the story
settings villains could have been
involved or even the root cause of the
uprising this could very well be why
Prince Adam undertook the unification of
all fairy tale kingdoms into the United
States of auradon King beast sacrifice
taking his new queen on a honeymoon so
he could form the USA he demonstrated
his commitment to the kingdom that kind
of display would have won him public
approval the founding of auradon was a
huge moment in the history of Disney's
fairy tale kingdoms living heavily in
the USA with her king Belle was finally
able to turn her attention to building a
family the revolution in her own kingdom
was chaos there would have been years of
rebuilding and regrowth those lean years
aren't the time to be responsible for a
baby founding an entirely new alliance
in auradon and banishing all of the
villains would have taken all of Prince
Adam and Belle's time and attention that
didn't leave room in their lives for
children either but our Dawn's founding
welcomed a new age of very much needed
peace it was the perfect time to bring
Belle and beasts child into the world
Ben must have been an adorable little
boy he's so handsome and charming as a
teenager
we can't help but
imagine a little boy with blonde
ringlets and a blue and gold romper
Belle must have been so excited to show
off her beautiful child we imagine Belle
reading all of the parenting books she
could get her hands on and maybe even
writing a few Bell as a mom can you
imagine her messy brown bun and gold
yoga pants we can't help but imagine her
with a large coffee and a t-shirt that
says mama beast even if that wasn't
quite the picture we bet she was an
amazing mother there's no way that been
turned out so compassionate responsible
and progressive if he wasn't raised
exceptionally well Belle's life really
is a fairy tale she got to fall in love
with a handsome prince she lives in a
beautiful enchanted castle surrounded by
friends she's the queen of a progressive
and sparkling Kingdom she has a brave
intelligent and handsome son anyone
would be lucky to walk a mile in her
silk slippers we're happy for Belle that
she got her happily ever after her story
began with fear and struggle she showed
her courage and integrity at every turn
she stood by her friend beast until her
heart filled with love for him she
befriended his staff and tried to save
them from their curse she stood up for
herself against fearsome enemies and
angry mobs Belle earned the happy life
she has now she's a good person who's
loyal and compassionate and we're so
glad she's living her best life what do
you think about Bill's happily ever
after come let us know in the comments
we hope you enjoyed this look at Belle's
life after happily ever after we'll see
you next time
[Music]